[Applause]
[Music]
the final episodes of jeopardy hosted by
the late alex trebek will air this week
starting tonight the first of the five
episodes
includes a message from trebek about the
season of giving
the final episode will include a tribute
to the beloved host
trebek died of pancreatic cancer in
november at age 80.
liam neeson must protect a boy on the
run in the upcoming movie
the marksman what the hell that kid they
were gonna kill him they were waiting
for him at the border
nissan plays jim a retired marine
enjoying a solitary life as a rancher
along the arizona mexico border
but his peaceful life is upended when he
meets a boy fleeing from members of a
vicious cartel
the marksman premieres in theaters next
week
and a crash-landed alien tries his best
to fit in on earth
and the new sci-fi comedy resident alien
my son told me you're an alien
well you don't have anything to worry
about i'm not an alien
thank you for coming over the show based
on a comic book
follows harry an alien who tries to pass
himself off as a small town human doctor
after arriving on earth but things get
rocky when he's roped into solving a
local murder investigation
resident alien premieres on sci-fi
january 27th
that's your eye on entertainment chris
martinez cbs news los angeles